when the u.n secretary general comes to
town it usually means things aren't
going well
but they may get better
antonio gutierrez has made his position
clear climate change caused the floods
in pakistan a disaster forced upon poor
countries by rich ones
so it is time to settle the bill the
government and millions of people
affected by floods hope his visit helps
loosen western purse strings what is
your message to the people who are
anchored firmly in the worst part of
this crisis
my message is that the world has a
responsibility to support them that the
world must help pakistan at the present
moment for pakistan to be able to rescue
all the people in those dramatic
circumstances
the u.n delegation has heard first-hand
accounts from survivors and rescue teams
of tragedy suffering and growing
desperation the rains and the raging
rivers may have stopped for now but that
does not mean that all the danger is
gone what the pakistani government is
trying to showcase
here in this place where people have
been seeking refuge they want to
illustrate to the u.n secretary general
that despite the fact that much of the
dramatic weather is over there still
remain for the people that are living in
or near the flood zones they'll still
remain immediate threats to their lives
nowhere more so than in synth province
where earlier this week there was a
forced breach of the country's largest
freshwater lake settlements sacrificed
to save cities
and remote villages is where people need
the most help i think people are slow to
react because the problem is so big that
it seems unapproachable and the first
thing is to just take a first step and
get your team here get your boots on the
ground
volunteers say the government must cut
through red tape if these visas are not
the the process is not sped up fast
enough then
it's gonna it's gonna end up with a lot
of people left with no help or no
support no kind of relief no kind of
rehabilitation
international aid is arriving but it
quickly becomes clear that it is still
not enough medics tell us people are
suffering from malaria water-borne
illnesses serious infections that
started as small wounds they admit
people need more help than they are able
to give
zayn basravi al-jazeera larkana sindh
pakistan